our next guest is a drew gooder as we
call them around here who takes giving
back to a whole new level i'm really
inspired by isaiah garza who has made it
his mission to help strangers in need
while sharing his
journey and like i said he's got almost
7 million followers on tick tock i mean
he has really made a dent his posts have
gone viral
he has a billion views
um and he's proof that kindness just
exists in the world and when we need to
know it when i need to know it i look to
his videos watch this
what's something i could do right now
for you that would put a smile on your
face
if you can buy me a tent why are you a
tent yes sir i got you a tent brother
i know you needed a tent right yes sir
you got that smile i see it already this
is one of the best days of my life you
look like a beautiful mom with your kids
and i have some flowers if you wanted
some thank you so much i wanted to give
you these flowers
yeah give them to your wife how long you
guys been together for 30 over 30 years
30 years oh wow
wow
i remember you told me how much it mean
to get your hair done so i got you an
appointment to go get your hair done
right now
how does that sound to you it sounds
good wow
what do you think i love it this has
been amazing for me today thank you
please welcome isaiah garza
you
you grew up in washington
um you loved vogue growing up oh yeah
you have a whole fashion story too oh
yeah yeah i mean you've actually have
jewelry on like selena gomez rihanna
cardi b yeah which is insane because
that's like not even the lead story with
you
how did you come up with your style the
way you do things the way you video
how did this all come about what was
your inspiration
um the pandemic actually is what
inspired me you know uh i would see
consistently you know families going
through really hard times because of
covid and families just really
struggling and so much media covering
that portion of people struggling right
going through so many hard times
and i was like why not this be the time
where you just put out the best most
heartfelt inspiring content you could
possibly put out where people need to
see that during this hard time you know
you yourself have experienced
hardship and difficulty that makes you
understand the journey of others can you
tell me about that absolutely i mean
i've been homeless multiple times in my
life i've slept in my car many times
when i was a kid you know we lost our
house we got our cars repossessed
we just i remember christmases where we
had no we had no heater we could and a
lot of times where we had no presence
under the tree you know and um i
remember one time just seeing my dad
crying you know when we lost our cars
and the hardship we went through is
something that actually inspired me to
want to do what i do today um and your
father is here actually dad
[Applause]
as well as your
how did you raise a son like this and
are you so proud very very proud of my
son
and the thing is that when you grow up
as a parent
you should teach
your kids
how to be and he's taught me
how to be
[Applause]
i mean
to hear your dad say that what does that
make you feel
that's like as a kid that's all you can
dream of you know is make your parents
proud you know
so that's everything that i already feel
like i accomplished everything in life
you know by that you know so
your beautiful girlfriend is here who i
just met as well
i mean
it must be nice you know all of us uh
are looking for a partner who
can inspire us and be an example
what are your conversations like at home
[Laughter]
we definitely talk about his work a lot
he shares his
ideas for projects even though i've
never heard a bad project idea that got
shot down or didn't get fully realized
he's a really powerful person and he's
really easy to love
[Applause]
um
you inspire so many people that um today
um
we heard from some of them and uh they
actually made a video for you this time
let's take a look
isaiah hi
from all of us here at eisenhower high
school we just want you to know how
proud we are of you coming from a high
school where the majority of us here are
latino it really fills me with a great
sense of pride it really makes me want
to succeed in this world when i see
another latino from yakima washington
who's really succeeding in life every
time i have a student tells me that they
they can't do it or they have no purpose
in life or no goals i tell your story
the fact that you came from yakima
washington and went off to do all these
amazing things is super inspirational
keep spreading positivity the way you do
well isaiah there is one more thing um
the mayor of your hometown in yakima
washington patricia berry sent us a
certificate of appreciation to thank you
for all that you've done
oh my god
[Applause]
more
wow
[Music]